here we go again this is the Wednesday
morning poster session we'll try to find
some cool papers it's just as big as all
the other poster sessions goes from all
the way back
there to all of this Hall
here insane
[Music]
insane hi hi hey big fan nice meeting
you I'm recording a bit is that okay
yeah sure can you tell us about vations
in RN TR in RNN training oh okay now I'm
getting
nervous like General rundown like we
were interested in finding uh hope RNN
training Works um why we have sometimes
problems the way we did that is so for
example first we use like normal R
activated RS yeah and the reason we do
that is because we're analytically
practical so we actually have a close
form solution for fix points and K
cycles and that we can calculate like
it's just this equation and the bation
is just like a qualitative change in
your dynamical behavior of your system
so changing from fix Point Behavior to
CYCC Behavior so what what kind of stuff
are you training here do you somehow
assume an infinite length sequence of
inputs or so how do you talk about fix
points for the benchmarks we lose like
uh Brands like Lawrence system and like
that and for example here we have like
empirical uh data from membrane voltage
tracers of cells so we got a recording
and we trained on that yeah and what we
found is that during training like you
have like this big jumps in the in the
loss and we use our um algorithm to
analyze what kind of Dynamics are going
on okay and what we had here uh was like
we have a fixed point after the chump so
you see before the chump we have a
fairly well trained system it's not
perfect but you see it's like close to
uh what we actually want and then
suddenly at this point we go to
basically Infinity yeah last time we
have like Divergent Behavior can you
tell us a bit so what's the data exactly
here that's a Time series exactly it's a
Time series of a membrane voltage so we
recorded not we but like the people we
got the data from they recorded it on a
cell they recorded the uh the membrane
voltage over time so you you yeah just
toage and do you think the problem has
to do with the fact that there's these
spikes in the data and so on and these
might be
discontinuities in general you always
see like this kind of behavior if you
train rnms like you always have like
this trumps okay uh in the loss because
of those types of fication even if I
train like a language RNN or language
RNN like an R an an RNN on uh I don't
know like
some sentence of language yeah I would
say like in general what we observe is
that always it looks something like this
usually you have always those uh Chumps
in in the L not always that big like
that is like exceptional but usually
always have like um weekly behavior in
your loss you're never like completely
uh straight and it's just because your
loss landscape is like uh very crooked
at some point you have like those Chums
in the in the loss landscape what we
wanted to do is what we wanted to
calculate all those dynamical objects we
want to find the fix points we want to
calculate the case cycles of those
objects we can relate that to the bation
curves like for example this is a 2d
example this is like analytically
calculated um bation curves so we know
for example here this srl this is the
region where we have a stable two cycle
yeah um this would be where we have a
stable three cycle and here we have like
multi-stability so we have both existing
at the same time and this is all
analytically calculated and now we and
it give us a background a two cycle and
a three cycle are what ccle and just be
like yeah you have like the time series
here so two cycle would be the red one
where you just St jump between two
states
and the would be juming between three
states and those states are weights like
you jump from one weight configuration
to another no you have one fixed weight
configuration since a Time series
produced by your model like States jump
States I see yeah and uh we try to
reproduce that with like um our approach
which is a semi analytical uh but we
calculate just like at on a grid here we
calculate those dynamical objects and we
actually find all of those by curves
okay this was basically a validation for
for our code to see that we actually
work the problem with like this um
analytical approach is you have an
equation like for a fix point in every
single of those linear regions given by
your relo activation function and in
generally you would need to solve for
every single of those linear regions
which is going to be tedious if you have
like a 100 dimensional RNN uh like it
scales with two to the power of your
dimension like the the quadrants um so
the the idea we came up with was is
sistic where you like initialize in one
random quadrant and then you calculate
your equation like the definition would
be now if the solution lies in the same
quadrant then you have a real fix point
so you will just stay there um if your
solution lies in another quadrant then
will be a virtual fix point so if you
are here you will feel attracted to that
but uh as soon as you cross over it
doesn't exist anymore so yeah um the
idea would be now to reinitialize the
algorithm the calculation here in um
that virtual in the quartum of that
virtual fix point so wherever you go or
you re exactly and it works surprisingly
well so here is like a scaling example
the black one would be like just uh if
you would randomly pick a quadrant and
uh calculate it there it would uh scale
like that and those are like how our
algorithm scale so it depends a lot on
like the IG vectors uh on the uh on the
Matrix Norms yeah um but in general it
always scals better than by just
randomly looking at those quadrants yeah
and then we use that algorithm to
actually calculate bation Curves in like
for example in this toy example and you
see all those like this is the loss
gradient and this is the loss uh the
actual loss and you see that uh all the
Chumps in the loss are actually lined by
bation curves yeah which means uh
whenever you have a chump in the loss
it's probably caused by a bation yeah uh
but not every bipoc causes like a l chel
always depends and like coming from that
toy example we did that on the real data
and what we found uh was we find these
types of fications in that training as
well the cool thing is we cannot only
analyze training process but we can
analyze a fully trained system so our
goal is not just to do good prediction
but we do dynamical systems um dynamical
systems to construction yeah so we
actually want the full dynamical system
and not just good prediction and we once
we're trained here we can calculate all
the dynamical objects like what we have
here is for example stable 39 cycle
which would describe the cycle you can
see here okay but that's not everything
we found we also found like a stable fix
point that exists at the same time and
then uh we have this unstable 9 cycle uh
and we have an unstable 39 cycle and the
question is now like if we have a real
proxy for the biological system this
should have a meaning like this fix
point would mean something yeah so this
is what what we're going to work on like
in the future like uh relating that to
actual biological uh things coming back
to the training yeah what we found is
that like a form of teacher forcing like
generalized teacher forcing uh that was
proposed at icml this year um actually
helps a lot in getting rid of those
crazy jumps okay like this degenerate
transcritical bifurcation that causes
that jump uh is not possible if you
choose your uh Factor Alpha here
correctly so you smooth your loss
landscape and you make RNN training
easier like and much faster okay so you
you found why this method helps exactly
yeah we found out why this actually
works yeah pretty cool very nice the fix
points that you found you said they must
be explained somehow by Something Real
the
39 39 cycle six point fix point would be
the spikes do you have a clue what the
nine cyle will be so it might it might
still be just an artifact from from the
training so this is something we have to
figure out and uh you have to find
metrics to say okay is this now fully
trained are we really like do we
actually have a proxy for the system
yeah but yeah that's like the work in
progress what we actually want to do now
like uh sometimes you just get artifacts
during the training process and
sometimes uh it might have a meaning but
yeah that's something we want to figure
out now very cool thank you so much than
a thank you man nice to meet you nice to
meet you radi let's focus on this one
tell me about it this he's very cool
follow him on Twitter l++ is a technique
that leverages the semantic guidance but
for editing real images while semantic
guidance edits images on the lat space B
of stable diffusion l++ add its real
images so but we first do inversion so
we take an image and we invert it back
into the latent space but we do DPM
solver Plus+ inversion which is an
innovation on this paper because no it
hasn't been done before and basically
you can do inversion in as little as 50
steps maybe even less what what kind of
models do you invert uh basically you
can do any any pre pre-trained text to
image diffusion model so here we do
stable diffusion 1.52 or XL um and
essentially it's the combination between
the the inversion then applying the
semantic guidance technique so we can uh
guide for example Yan leun to be George
Coy with sunglasses so you do two edits
at once it's and it's all inference time
you don't need pre-training you don't
need uh further fine tuning and uh
another Innovation from the that's y++
from the from the tech te is that we do
centic grounding so these masks are
already free on this table diffusion
unit uh both the the unit masks and also
the noise masks and when you use them
you essentially ground your edits into
the into the the model in it what does
it mean using them do I have to do
something or so basically this means
that so here for example uh no masking
and no pipelining model so you don't
need to segment anything connected
basically just type cherry blossom and
the model finds that uh already it has
the knowledge that there is a tree here
so it replaces the three with with the
cherry blossom without you having to
point where the cherry blossom is and
also you remove the yellow car so this
is the original image right the car was
yellow so basically we remove yellow car
we add Green Convertible and we add
cherry blossom and uh basically for free
without saying without masking without
saying where the model semantically
finds the cherry blossom the it removes
the yellow car and it adds a green
convertible but you see it kept a lot of
the structure you kept the background
and this but it does the mask after it
did this or it does it uses the mask to
do this it uses the The Mask to do it so
you type because there is no cherry
blossom here right so you say plus
cherry blossom it would kind of
semantically find that cherry blossom is
a tree and therefore the tree is here
and you could use that just the
Reconstruction so you don't where do you
start you start from reconstruction yeah
um when you want to do an or when you
want to edit a real image you first have
to find the not from which you start to
actually edit the and that's why you
have to reconstruct the that's why you
have to yeah I think Reconstruction is
maybe not the right work here but
anyway so you start from from from this
image you invert it um and then when you
want to do the text editing
as po was saying the word is grounded in
the image so the model has a knowledge
on Where cherry blossom is relevant in
the image and so it limits the editing
already to the based on the uh model's
knowledge to the relevant image region
that's quite cool because like we're
really focusing on the relevant Parts um
and get Mas for free Yeah Yeah so
basically this this for example is is
what you would do if you just do the
inversion reconstruction and the textual
editing without the the the mass
grounding yeah you see that it actually
does it right you do add the cherry
blossom and you kind of change the car
but like it looks a bit like the the the
car light is a bit has a bit of the
cherry blossom Vibe like with the pink
and the the the car kind of changed
quite a lot yeah um so with with the
grounding by using the the knowledge of
the model of the masks and it's an
averaging of both the unit and the noise
yeah um it manages to actually do way
better edit nice very cool very cool and
this all for free all for free all
inference time the only the only tricky
the only tricky thing is that you have
to do inversion so right so like the
first step you have to like run the 50
steps of inversion uh to then but then
once the one image is inverted like once
you have all the Laten you can reuse you
don't need to do inversion every time
you do it once and then in is free
theion takes roughly a second so it's
still quite quite quick yeah but uh and
it's also reconstruction ER free so it's
like perfect inversion uh and fast
inversion so it's not really a downside
I
think very cool then excent thank
you enjoy rest
question it okay if I record a
bit feel free I will try my best very
cool thank you uh so this work we
basically investigate is it possible for
that model to be performant without any
fixed token betting so fixed token
betting is basically it has been here
since the first world to so it's like
mapping from token to fix M if you don't
have this that means the token no longer
have this identity being incomex
independent identity you only have token
meaning by how it acts the
comp so Lexi varies is basically like
this uh idea like these three phrases
are equivalent because it's only
different after two lexal mapping so
letter e here you can obviously is a
because e appears here and here and here
and here and the same c as a yeah so
this is a Lexi varus so we basically
show that this Lear L model can converge
to standard length model in terms of
next token prediction which is very
surprising because you have this
property uh and we show empirically also
does the same thing so Le VAR L model uh
we kind of constructed by replacing
fixed token embedding Transformer with
random gion embedding so basically this
uh the E here will receive the same
token edding the same random gion Vector
token edding the same place in the
sequence but across different sequences
the same e will have different B oh did
you like kind of intuitively explain how
the Rand go
in Yeah so basically
as saying like basically you the letter
e here right it
receives I just like literally romly
sample caution Vector for M and the same
e here will have the same R caution
bding I
replaces and so similar C has the same
ring and K
hasing oh like the ined is like the
first occurrence of that character
whichever m
you can secure
that okay and butross different
sequences your same letter will have
different C bding so that you force it
to have larious
property what do you predict then do you
predict into a standard vocabulary uh no
you predict in the still in C Bing the
random C Bing so let's let's say but
what if you don't have that particular
letter that you want oh you don't have
it yet that's a good question so then
you cannot really predict it out so that
one will just be you can't you can't do
anything there okay does that mean you
have
to uh no you can do any
tokenization you just need to replace
whatever token
uh question but um so like right if it's
all random and let's say you have will
this be able to predict a letter that's
not there no that's the thing won't be
able to or a token that's not there
right so if you tokenize so if your
token like if your vocabulary is really
large if you go beyond like character
you do like yeah that's why it need a
really large
context and and all the C in the input
if you CH the
input it's it's not
so usually and this is perplexity on
language modeling on an
RNN uh no this is a cal proof okay that
this is nothing to do with this this is
all Transformer so all the empirical
stuff of this deer only Transformer okay
and perplexity is usually measured sort
of in on the log scale so this
difference here would actually be quite
big no yeah this difference is that yeah
so it kind of derives that uh all it
does from just kind of how tokens relate
to each other yeah exactly okay yeah so
that's a key uh and we also show that
model performs incomplex to suffering
with and so basically because it
literally it it sees all the
substitution Cipher as the same sequence
so it literally performed impul this com
deciphering you can prile the cipher Key
by uh like just like tring a linear L on
top of the
Frozen yeah
uh and we finally show that s model is
subtit better at the symbol manipulation
task so symbol manipulation task we have
two tasks so one is a lookup table so
you have a lookup table and you predict
the next token by looking up what's
token that's to and the other one is a
pration so you permute the sequence the
same way as the demonstration and we
show that we achieve 4X improvements on
this but these are very constructed to
favor you a little bit okay
okay very cool so does does it mean that
a lot of language is just sort of how
things relate to each other and not just
the absolute words yeah yeah okay it's
very interesting very cool thank you y
nice to meet you Transformers Implement
preconditioned grading descent for Inon
Ah that's very cool so you figure that
if in context Learning Happens what's
actually happening is some sort of oh
yeah we are yeah we
exactly idea is that if you want to
solve this square with the
Transformer and you train it on the
random data generated to Sol Square the
network when it when you increase the
number of layers the network cross the
layers in implementing some algorithm
which is a precondition gradient this
this how how we can find this
characterize it to study the structure
of the object itive that is used to
optimize the parameters you characterize
what is the optimum parameter you plug
in it there and see what happens and
then you can interpret it as an
Al so how do you get a Transformer to
even tackle least squares what do you do
as the inputs and outputs sure the
inputs are x i y i in context example of
L Square we encode one example of so all
of this is in context and then this is
the sort of next token you predict okay
okay and that's you solve these that's
very very
cool and then you train on a lot of
these
examples okay I would expect that
Transformer to just kind of memorize a
lot of stuff it seems like you're more
you're actually doing an algorithm
internally that doesn't mean okay that's
very interesting so you can there is
memorization as you said that's correct
the memorization is in the so suppose
that you have a
data that is with
some then the optim parameters that you
find depends on the sigma Matrix depends
on the spectrum of the sigma
Matrix so there is a
memorization exactly the algorithm ads
to data yeah become
PR but it's not that
different okay okay the memorization
accounts for the preconditioning it's
not about the existence it's actually
very cool and then yeah how do you how
do you make this actually in how do you
interpret it into an algorithm then so
once you have the
preconditioning oh mat very good
question because we are updating
data not so we don't have of this
Square the way that you can connect
these two is that you can prove that
this Y and plus has different instances
across the layers it's getting updated
across the layers when you pass the data
across the layer this why why at the
beginning it was Zero it become
something and something at the end also
you track how it evolves over the layers
and that's kind of the algorithm then
this would be equivalent of projecting
this gradient step on the xn + one okay
so this is the way that you show this
theoretically so theoretically for
single layer we can say Global Optimum
is exactly this algorithm you can say
what is a
preconditioning for multi layer the
result is weaker wey we prove there is a
stationary point that is great
yeah we couldn't say it's Global minimum
local minimum just a
station and then you try it out in
practice in practice we optimize it and
we found that is even for multi-layer we
are converging to the same structure
that we character the same let say
stationary exactly very cool very
Awesome's the implication thanks for the
explanations
hello hello nice me you I've seen your
videos is it okay if I record a bit of
course of course of course I'd love like
to give you the speed if you'd like to
hear it I I I would love to uh amazing
yeah so uh so basically the motivation
of doing this work was that we saw the
very great potential of uh human
preferences in language domain yeah you
obviously know with from open Assistant
chgb Etc and we wanted like we we wanted
selfishly we we wanted to do it in TX
generation but the problem was that
there was no large publicly available
data sets to to do it with so we decided
that we will uh that we that we'll
collect one and open source it mhm so we
did it by creating website that enables
users to generate uh images from text
for free that's actually like screenshot
from the website so the users were able
to uh enter the website write their own
inventive prompts generate images and
and to see the next image they needed to
choose uh which image they prefer yeah
this allowed us to collect the data set
that contains more than one million
examples of human preferences in text to
image yeah in which each image contains
a prompt two images and a preference for
which image is preferred or if there is
no like hard
preference and you can take a look at
this data it's very very very different
than the data that you'd see Ms ccoo for
example M the images are much more
diverse much more interesting and the
prompts can be like can be funny scary
and not boring like
msop and cool so this data set is great
but we also wanted to show that we can
actually utilize it so it's kind of like
so what we've done is we trained a
scoring function that we call pick score
it's clip a scoring function that is
supposed to estimate the level of
satisfaction of the user
from the image given the propt so that's
a reward model exactly we wanted to
return a reward model put it simply yeah
and the input is a prompt in an image
and the output is a score yeah and we
used like we used to put it bluntly we
used analogous subjective of instruct
GPD and then when we
measured H pix score's ability to
predict human preferences we show that
surprisingly it's not only better than
existing scoring functions yeah it's
even better than experts and that like
like those people like say like but wait
that doesn't make sense was created by
humans so I can be super human and the
core distinction is that the user that
created that created that example has
much more information that the crowd
worker yeah the crow worker is only can
only get us input like the prompt and
the the and the images yeah they don't
know like what the user had in mind what
they envisioned and the model needs to
pick up on that or the craft worker so I
think that it's it like it shows an
important Insight also this fact that
you also like probably saw in open
Assistant that real users she can
provide you with much higher quality
data than crowd workers yeah here your
incentive was like this is a free free
image generation yeah the incentive for
the user for the users was like free
very high quality image generation and
our incentive was we want to uh to uh
open source stuff for the community and
to uh P research yeah so using the
scoring function we show that we can
perform much better model evaluation M
than the one that can be done with fid
which is which is the standard metric
for evaluating text to image models yeah
but it shouldn't be because it's a very
bad metric that doesn't even consider
the PRS yeah so yeah so pix score
correlates better in model evaluation
better than fid on Ms Coco yeah and
better than other scoring functions on
um yeah this is it's small difference no
no this is minus uhuh this if I shows
negative correlation but then I could
still I could still
predict yeah just by taking the negative
yeah yeah but see like but see like it's
like like yeah actually I agree but uh
but but but yeah
yeah that's a fact if it's so Nega that
negatively correlated yeah that's a fact
but I'm sure that people won't like
start like uh oh we've been doing it the
opposite direction like all isn't the D
for distance yeah for Inception distance
small distance good yeah but but here we
took but here we took the winning
average between the models okay so we
took obviously we took account for the
fact that F like smaller obviously like
okay good and cool so we suggest you
update the standard protocol yeah for
evaluating text to image models by
taking uh promps from Pik a peek yeah
rather than Ms Coco captions and to use
pix score rather than FID
Y and can you also use PX score to
evaluate let's say Gans without chrum so
that's a very interesting question and
I'd love for followup work to see how
well how well generalizes yeah I'd love
to see it I don't have like a definitive
answer for that H yeah so so the next
thing that we try to do is we try to
think of like the simplest way to
improve text to image generation with
big score yeah so what we did very
navely we just took the vanilla model
yeah generated a bunch of images yeah
scored them and just return yeah
selected the best yeah and we can see
both qualitatively and quantitatively
yeah that pix score usually selects a
better image both than the original
model and more than Aesthetics predictor
or clip MH and finally I think that it
can be interesting to um to put some
context before because the those
conference these conferen has happened
like several months after we publish
yeah yeah so since then the both the
both scoring function and the other set
was pretty widely adopted yeah and two
notable works that I really really loved
and like wanted to like highlight a bit
in my poster was making P score a metric
for text guided video editing benchmark
H to measure video quality and very very
interesting work by wedal improved SD
Exel by extending DPO for diffusion
models and doing it on p a PE data set I
see so and they were able to improve
sdxl and I'm going to guess this was
sdxl or or some Sable diffusion already
it was it was lots of different PS we
wanted to make it it's more diverse yeah
cool awesome so it's this is it is
actually the whole Loop is a bit like
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback right like ultimately okay
definitely yeah and uh yeah I hope that
people will continue like to look at the
stuff continue to open source and uh
yeah awesome thank you very much yeah
nice meeting you in person nice meeting
you not even read the title so you have
to introduce me so this paper is about
image geolocalization so image GE
localization means giving image we want
to identify the GPS coordinates of it
GPS coordinates means the latitude
longitude of it right so suppose you are
given a particular image you want to
know which location this image has been
taken from yeah the problem here is this
image can be taken in the any world any
any any part of the whole world yeah so
you have to match it throughout the
world and identify the location of it
what kind of data do you have available
Street View street view okay yeah so
that's so this is like geogas kind of
yeah yeah yeah so so it's like a
worldwide image right you want to do at
the World level Global level
so existing approaches they do it VI
classification based approach so they
divide the whole earth into grids and
then they classify which grid the
particular image belongs to but the
problem is the grid center location is
the GPS coordinate always they say that
but if the image belongs deviates from
that then localization cribs in and also
number of classes depends on the how
many how many classes you taking so we
avoid those approaches we take a
retrieval based approach and there are
also some approaches which are image to
image retrieval approach yeah but we
don't do image to image because you need
to have a gallery of the whole world
whole earth which is not possible to
have so we take image to GPS retri so
what we do is we pass the image to image
encoder clip based image encoder yeah
and there a gallery of GPS coordinates
we pass it to location encoder to get
location features okay and then we do
contrastive Lear yeah so now the
challeng is these are 2D coordinates we
want to get a high dimension
representation right for that this is
our location encoder
so how to do that so let's say this is
the GPS coordinates we first pass it to
equal projection mhm so normal GPS
coordinates traditional laong have
inherent distortions some countries are
over represented some countries are less
represented near the polar regions and
so on so forth so we do a better
representation equal representation okay
then after this again 2D only so then
what we do is we pass it to random Foria
features random for features is a signos
ining technique
so we take a matrix R sampled from some
gion then multiply it and then have SS
and cosin of but here if you take a
particular Sigma it is capturing a
particular type of frequencies so we
want to capture frequencies spanning
from both uh corser to fine grain
because we want to perform well on both
course I mean fine grain and also course
and fine grein both this is F this
course MH so we take a series of sigmas
pass it to Dedicated MLPs combine them
by simple addition operation that is our
feature so you have a multifrequency
like the all the frequencies in in
combined together it's like a random up
projection but in different frequency or
so now uh these are performance on these
different data sets yeah and across
different threshold metrics performance
is better and also the good thing is if
you have a text as a query you can
replace this uh through a text replace
the image encoder through text encoder
is already pre-trained you don't have to
train it again and this is also
implicitly aligned so you can get a
similarity scores for all the GPS
coordinates you can get a similarity map
kind of a thing yeah right so your if
the text query is Desert let's say with
a generic query it can so it is able to
localize throughout the world yeah and
also if it's a specific City or specific
landmarks is
Aizer and lastly the thing is the
location encoder can be used for other
tasks also okay if you have a task like
classification you can also use our
location features to combine the image
features and get better
performance very cool very cool um would
it be I'm I'm just guessing but street
view is sampled very differently
throughout the world right so here
you're kind of trying to get the area
you know relative to the size but could
you also have a transformation that just
transforms so that where street view
pictures are more often you you get like
higher density of grid points right
right right would you would you expect
that to help that helps actually yeah so
our Gallery during Gallery construction
we try to use the training set knowledge
training set data has been prepared via
uh more I mean more samples from those
region where human reside less samples
from those which are not important like
oceans or deserts so we that prior
knowledge in the training set we utilize
that one so we randomly sample the train
set to create our gallery yeah that
helps better than randomly sampling the
whole earth yeah okay very cool very
cool and yeah I wonder like what what
what you can use this this stuff for
will this mostly work for stuff that's
also represented in the images or I
don't know like what what here if you
enter for example I don't know
Christianity what would would sort of
the the Christian World light up or is
it only things that you know kind of
repres presented in street view images
so it might be possible um what happens
to that is that whatever features are
left in the beding space are the ones
that are useful for geolocalization yeah
right so for examp you if you have the
quer Christianity given there's so many
places that are like Christian it
wouldn't be a feature that make a
recogniz so maybe that Dimension will be
collapsed when passing through the
features like different linear layers
and do you have the do you have the same
model for all of these granularities or
do you train like different models we
have the same model for all the
granularities
and you just rely on sort of the
different embedding sizes you have there
yeah very cool very cool have you
competed in geog guer with this we would
like to actually you haven't tried we
haven't tried yet there's this uh
there's a couple of these YouTubers
right rainbow and yeah exactly you got
you have to call them and be like hey we
have a new best new best AI and they'd
be pumped yeah that would be cool to try
yeah all right thank you very much thank
you pleasure thank you very cool work
videos and explanations are too good
very nice thank you thank you very much
is it okay if I record yeah okay what do
my text that image classifiers have to
do with Hardware oh uh so basically what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
use those uh text features that are
generated from the text and then trying
to initialize the last layer by you
instead of like doing a random
initialization for the last layer that
based on how we do previously we wanted
to use those class descriptions or those
text descriptions and then pre-train the
last layer and then now you can plug in
any machine learning architecture that
you have resonate Alex net or even your
own classification architecture with it
and then use it to trade it so what it
does is when you do those uh like text
descriptions uh and then like initialize
the last layer it makes the model more
confident enough for it to actually be
resilient when bit flip errors or as
manufacturing defects actually happen on
the hardware okay so the original
problem is a hardware defect exact in
what exactly in the image sensor or in
the um the hardware defect is actually
like we're talking about the deployment
when the models are trained and then
deployed on the hardware yeah when
Hardware could be like could be affected
by like voltage droops uh manufacturing
defect and so on and then when that
happens silent data Corruptions actually
happen on the model which makes on the
it doesn't crash the system rather it
makes the model do like wrong inferences
instead of the right ones okay so if I
imagine I train my model for myself
driving car I deploy it in the car the
model gets corrupted and then my car
just kind of gets worse yeah it might
like speed up when it shouldn't or it
might actually like detect something
incorrect okay so that's this part right
here this part might get worse exactly
okay and then so like this is the your
so after inputting this is your final
model like this is your final
architecture so uh if you didn't have
when this one gets corrupted now it'll
be lead doing wrong inferences instead
of the right one yeah and so what's your
method exactly doing to counter that um
basically like this on it gives us all
the features and what happens here is
that we actually have instead of like
initializing the last layer values
randomly it gives it the initial setup
or a smart way to give it the initial
setup and whenever you're doing that
training it'll be more confident on
whatever inferences that is going to
make okay so this is let's say an image
classifier Y and you initialize this
here somehow yeah to make it more robust
exactly what does this have to do with
text input exactly okay so basically
what we do is let's say you have like 10
classes yeah so uh currently we use CH
GPT gpt3 so we ask gpt3 multiple
questions for each class and the gbtc
gave us multiple descriptions so we took
those descriptions and then we gave it
to clip to give us the embeddings and
then those embeddings now we have
multiple descriptions with embedding so
we averaged that one so now we actually
have a more robust information about
that image and then after averaging it
we use that to initialize the projection
layer so you just get somehow some sort
of a class embedding that you get out of
all of these exactly uh texts about the
different classes that you get from sort
of the clip text encoder yeah that's
very smart um and
uh but but how why do you think it helps
again so if if I corrupt something here
right then you're saying this is more
robust now why do you think that is yeah
well the thing is like when bit flips
let's say if a bit flip happens like in
the beginning layer or in between
there's a probability that since
convolutional neural networks when it's
doing like the when it's going through
there's high probability that of it
being corrected through the process by r
or other activation functions but if a
bit flip happens on the final layer it's
actually like affecting the final
decision of the model yeah so the best
way to actually increase the resilience
is what if we could actually focus on
the most vulnerable layer okay instead
of uh the hall and if so sometimes
people do check sums and things like
this I think Hardware gpus already have
sort of error correction built in
doesn't that also help or is what you're
doing kind of compl
to that yeah well like the existing like
the state of D or the existing one like
the parcy checks or a correcting course
mainly focus on the storage but it
doesn't cover the computational part
okay and like like let's say for example
Tesla include introduces full modular
Hardware redundancy on which they
introduce redundancy but with that what
comes is that Hardware is actually using
more power and since it has redundancy
it's actually like being latent and
taking more time in making the decision
of course
the compter science environment the lat
actually matters so what we're providing
is instead of uh providing a power
consuming and then more redundant
solution what if we could actually train
the model thinking about the hardware
resiliency I've seen very cool and then
you test that do you actually trash your
Hardware or do you just sort of
artificially corrupt some stuff yeah we
have a framework called Golden ey so
golden ey actually simulates a real time
Hardware environment on which we use
goldenite to do the error injections on
both the Baseline and then our proposed
model and then after doing that we check
uh two we we we have two uh options in
which we measure that's Delta L and top
to diff yeah so Delta L gives us the
overall information on what's Happening
when wrong and right inferences are
being made and top to shows us how
confident the model is when actually
making the classifications and then by
using that we see how the model is
actually resilient M based on the
injections we did on it very cool and is
it more resilient it is and like
surprisingly like um we achieve actually
5.5 times average resiliency Improvement
okay with up to 14 times Improvement and
then uh with the minimum drop of
0.3% on inaccuracy and then that
accuracy drop is actually mainly on the
noise not like on the noise image that
would that are only already highly
likely to be misclassified mhm very cool
so you're saying the where these things
matter most these flips and so on is in
the images that are already kind of
shaky not sure exactly so what we're
doing here is actually increasing the
model's confidence in making those
decisions okay so it actually increases
the model confidence across the board uh
but it most matters in the the ones that
are on the edge in on the border so yeah
yeah that's very very cool yeah thanks a
lot for the for the explanation thank
you so much thank you thank you have a
nice day thank you so much take
care